one is also very difficult because you
don't have a lot of space about here is
where you'll lose that space to get to
get around your
P so you have to stay you have to make a
hole keep it as I said the same thing
pull it through here through that hole
there so um we're coming to the end of
the day and I want to uh study the
techniques not the not the whole part
about
throwing
here what I'd like you to do is watch my
body and don't look at the foot and
think you know you look at the foot you
see this and people think that you're
entering this is Keyon this is what you
should be learning in the lower grades
what I'm doing is I'm actually
stimulating it by showing you the move
but this block torso isn't going
anywhere and
then this thumb's going to actually fall
to me but it'll look like it's falling
there it's actually going to fall to
me so I go one I get out when it falls
to me it stays within that 5
cm if it's all worked out all
right
the hip pulls it through and you got
your
REM if you did what you should be had
enough cut for now if you did want
cut you can do the cut the any trouble
with that
is if you think you're going to do a cut
of
G the person's got a good grip you end
up once you buil up this thing you were
saying about you feel it in the the
higher teachers once you've built up
that coke or
whatever a going to stop you it's like
you're just a a
Powerhouse how' you become a Powerhouse
you become a Powerhouse by getting all
these pieces
correct over
here over
years
you don't have to do this SL it's up to
you I'm doing it slow so you can hope
you Gras the tech technical parts